-Guess! I'm gonna be in the newspaper!
-That lady wants to interview us on TV!
-Most "likes" ever.
-Me too.
-How cool is that?
-Yeah!
Let's go home
and put these trophies on display!
I wish everyone thought
I was special.
♪ They say it doesn't matter ♪
♪ How you look or where you've been♪
♪ So why doI need a thousand likes♪
♪ To feel like Ifit in?♪
♪ I'd probably have it easy♪
♪ If Iwere the only kid♪
♪ But when you live withten superstars♪
♪ It's hard for you towin♪
♪ I wish I could be♪
♪ Someone extraordinary♪
♪ But I'm just me♪
♪ And that's tooordinary♪
♪ Is there evergonna be
A place in the spotlight just for me?♪
♪ When the world can finallysee
I'm special like my family♪
♪ Will there be a time♪
♪ When I really shine?♪
♪ Am I always gonna be♪
♪Plain old ordinaryme?♪
♪ Ah-ah-ah♪
♪ Plain old ordinary me?♪
♪ Am I alwaysgonna be♪
♪ Plain old, regular,boring♪
♪ Unremarkable, ordinary me?♪